how the gun rest my name welcome back to
SCP 189 it but why
please I don't what to do it I do
anything all right
it's what you get when you steal other
people sandwiches I guess
alright this game got an update I don't
know if I said or not been so oh okay
this game is also known as corridor
simulator 2012 Dave down a neck oh look
the updated success there lovely lovely
lovely that's an amazing update I'm glad
I gave it another try that's totally
worth it cuz they I mean they put it on
wall all right well you guys are number
three lovely lovely lovely lovely
apparently you can make it it's random
what happens so that's why I wanted to
give it another try plus they update it
so I mean I thought like I want to make
a patched floor number 20 I think I made
it's no problem
I mean it's okay no I'm a man what the
hell you scare me with your stupid radio
yet
polish snappy snoo that was not cool
snappish no I just got to keep up
someone breathing ice breath guy again
I guess it's after revenge what is that
a window hey I love windows alright they
added windows now in the corridor I
guess it's not really technically a car
door anymore then it's more like a nope
okay alright we're good there's so much
change or someone with an iron dick can
do this I hope maybe probably not
problem enter no senoritas in generous
okay
9 come on almost halfway baby we can do
this I'm not gonna scare quick I can do
it
the last episode we didn't actually see
what it floor I can baby yes where is he
nope alright okay I get it
forget it I don't want to make it oh
snap I get if you choose
oh I don't like this okay okay all air
do let off king kelana cough cough alone
I mean the burner will you do it off I
don't like it I don't wanna be fireproof
do for and nerf
all right this way I'll snap each new
okay fine I'll go here hello animes now
I don't like maces I never like no one
like me
no one likes a mate ah [ __ ] me alright
that's an end of mace I'm just gonna
keep corridor simulator Oh where's your
final when you need him seriously though
spot oh are you doing this I don't
appreciate it no sir no sorry I don't
appreciate
hate all right I'm practicing at least
it's something good I
thirteen that's not good number
all right again oh so someone dusting
out their sheets nothing bad in my name
or just slapping there okay I don't want
to talk about I'm sorry all right
I am on Florida I don't even know floor
15 lovely come do it again then I played
the regular STP and is horrible
I went probably 150 [ __ ] okay I get
it
oh oh oh snap its new okay all right
did you see that Oh what the hell is
this
Oh watch it oh snap no okay okay I like
them on Facebook and I read them every
once in a while to say I love you keep
doing a good job I'm sorry you kill so
many people you are all totally alright
Oh lovely love doubt despair never have
you decorated whoever's down here
there's someone Holly wants to read me
20 floors how's it possible making keep
burping that's the problem that's a
bigger problem with it all right there
better be an elevator when I'm finished
I'm just saying sick of this [ __ ]
oh I saw these like a boss now I don't
even need 20 - no problem Arsenio but
what's going on what's going on I'm
sorry I'm sorry I didn't mean to do it
[Music]
all right
I just keep going I suppose I mean I
don't find any reason why I shouldn't
keep keep going all right
most age lovely I love [ __ ] I only said
it twice more probably more than height
24 nothing I think of it it's 25 last
time I don't like this you just keep
popping up and be like hey how your dad
know like that he's Mike hey I'm I'm
gonna make you hump this was damned
damned is 26 pitches like someone's I
say hey Oh
I told me what backwards and you given
me to do it I win now stop with his
windows I find us señoritas OLED will
enough kick Alana cough cough Alana be
the bono doodler guff all right I think
I choose the right one yes I did lovely
don't see any problem just keeps making
me going this [ __ ] much - fantastic
that was what I was hoping for
totally 29 [ __ ] all right
ah it's over
I made it have a man I am an hour man I
always go sorry I don't know what that
is I'm gonna in here breasts haha do the
manly test yourself or a girly test or
this balls testing yes
hmm I'll even download link in
description holy [ __ ] that's that's
really scary
I'm shaking and sweating isn't that
lovely
anyway I got in here like I made the
door or neighbor's dog and that's my
girlfriend all right I'm gonna in here
seein and whatever video I make next
whatever you like
it's not bad eh ah oh my god Bob what is
he doing ah okay who is that
let's stop now indoors
no more doors I'm not the holic I'm